today I'll stick to football surprise
Matt Ryan stops by the show we we didn't
know it was coming but it's always great
when one of the greatest quarterbacks in
the last 20 years stops by stick to
football we could talk to him about a
lifetime to supply Gatorade actually
that's what waivers not colors right
which makes you a psychopath I don't
know I've seen the memes so it's like if
you call Gatorade the flavor not the
color will let it let it slip if you're
Matt Ryan but we're also kind of we're
gonna hand out Christmas presents to all
32 teams it's that time of year where
some of these by the way some of them
are meant to be funny so I don't get
upset at us and leave a one-star review
because we've made fun of your team
we're gonna make fun of all the teams
probably so just have fun with it it's
light-hearted but to start the show we
actually have some news to talk about it
came out that trail Suggs was cut by the
Arizona Cardinals and he wanted to go to
Baltimore it was out there I think Adam
Schefter even said it that if anyone
other than Baltimore claimed him he just
might not show up well Baltimore didn't
put a claim on him but it wouldn't have
mattered because the Kansas City Chiefs
put in a claim and at number 24 they had
the waiver priority so Suggs is headed
to Kansas City I actually love this move
by Brett Veatch even if Suggs doesn't
you know he's not gonna have eight sacks
in the last two weeks in the playoffs
but you're blocking the Ravens from
getting a difference-maker
that is what this like I don't care if
Suggs plays you're blocking him from
going to the team that the AFC runs
through right now and the Niners and
Saints also put in a waiver claim for
him so it seems like these these teams
with a playoff chance here really felt
like maybe Suggs can add something for
the Chiefs Alex Okafor Tora Peck Manuel
Aguas bin al I actually think he'll be
asked to contribute as a situational
pass rusher I do too and I think going
back to your point Matt about blocking
teams teams don't operate even in the
nutshell of hey we might see them in the
divisional round they operate in the
nutshell of we might see that team in
the Super Bowl
so you're thinking we don't want the
Saints and the Niners to get this guy
and obviously the Ravens if he had
cleared waivers and opted to just sign
there for a very low market value kind
of deal
when you look at subs like you said
there's an opening on this team for some
snaps he's got five and a half sacks
this year so it's not like there's
nothing left in the tank here and I
don't think the Chiefs are gonna be
asking him to play 80 90 percent of the
team's defensive snap so I like the move
I really do and for Kansas City getting
a guy that's been there before and all
the way is really important I think that
kind of stuff in the playoffs can't be
that you know valued enough when it
comes down to it and when you look at it
was a busy day on the transaction wire
really was Jackrabbit jinora Jenkins
goes to the Saints and if you watch them
demolish the Colts on Monday Night
Football
the only bad takeaway you could have had
is I don't know if you want Eli Apple
starting or playing a ton against really
good teams in the playoffs right now you
have a feisty physical guy who I think
with would you Norris especially he's
been just buried in a bad situation in
New York so when the Giants signed him
he was one of the hottest corners on the
market so getting him back in a team
where you're playing for something you
actually have a chance to win a Super
Bowl I think we'll see him motivated a
little more disciplined he's never gonna
be the most disciplined player on the
field that's kind of the beauty of his
game but both of these signings and like
you said with Kansas City this defense
now gets someone who's been there done
it you have tire and Matthew now you
have Terrell Suggs and Frank Clark has
had some playoff runs with Seattle he's
been dealing with a stomach virus where
he's lost like 10 pounds but he's now
playing very very well he's been banged
up all year do you have a core own
defense that is terrifying and I think
you have to have that also with Suggs
you can't under 8 the fact that even
though he was only there for a year with
Lamar Jackson he knows that team and
having someone who's familiar with the
Ravens and what John Harbaugh does and
what Lamar Jackson is like I think
that's incredibly valuable if you're
Kansas City it's you a Baltimore in the
AFC I think look what the Patriots how
they've been playing lately I don't I
don't think the AFC goes through New
England anymore I think Baltimore and
Kansas City are the two best team so
just a smart move by both these clubs
who look like they are making it a nice
ition for the postseason run here now
the other thing that's going on right
now Connor is underclassmen declaring
for the NFL Draft the deadline is
January 17th there's a three-day window
after that so the actual deadline is
basically January 20th for players to
declare for the draft we're getting some
decisions come in we're waiting on
others I think most notably this week is
a guy who decided to go back to school
that Stanford tackle Walker little a
junior who got hurt early this year
didn't see him play he makes the
decision to go back to school to try to
boost his stock while healthy instead of
you know playing the well I got hurt I'm
just gonna prep for the combine to go
ahead and enter I think this is smart by
Walker little when Stanford is losing a
lot of guys to the transfer portal
potentially but he decides to go back to
Palo Alto yeah I think when you look at
Walker little declaring for the draft
would have been a gigantic risk I think
when it comes down to it when you're
hurt something I want to make very clear
with Walker little somebody we talked
about a lot in our summer previews Matt
to be honest with you the film right now
is not great not we're just because he's
hurt you don't go well if he gets
healthy we know he's around 1 caliber
tackle I was not there yet before the
injury now on raw potential traits yes
he can get there but I'd like to see him
come back and I don't want to use the
word earn it the guy's a fine player
it's just that he needs to continue to
develop to get his stock where a lot of
people think it already is so that's one
move that I'm actually a very big fan of
for the player yeah I am too I really
like that he's decided to go back and
prove himself as healthy and I think
this year the offensive tackle class is
a little muddled with Andrew Thomas
Jedrek wills Tristan works
Walker little was gonna have a hard time
breaking into that group since he was
hurt now go back to school
prove yourself a little bit we didn't
get a chance to talk about it while I
was out sick Jordan Love declared for
the draft and there was a lot of
speculation in the last few weeks
Utah State he's a graduate junior so he
could have transferred gone to the grad
transfer route he decides to enter the
NFL Draft and we talked about this a
little bit on the Monday show but I
believe Jordan Love will be a
first-round pick now should he be
I don't know I don't think so but I
think he will be and if you want to
compare that to like Daniel Jones last
year none of us thought he should be
first-round pick but we all knew he
would be that he was going to be because
of supply and demand I think Jordan love
hopefully maybe this will be announced
but by the time this podcast comes out
hopefully he will be in Mobile at the
Senior Bowl I think that would be a
great step for his draft stock I don't
know who's advising him I am NOT but I
think that would be huge for him to go
to mobile show off his traits show his
coach ability get around a staff like
the Cincinnati Bengals and then whomever
else is gonna be there might be the
Miami Dolphins that could be really big
for his draft stock yeah I'm with you
there I think when you look at Jordan
Love it's something that you sit on the
Monday show during mock draft Monday you
watch the 2018 film and a lot of teams
are gonna ask themselves can we get this
guy back to playing at this level the
guy that threw for 32 touchdowns and
only turned the ball over with six
interceptions rather than the guy that
had 17 touchdowns and 16 interceptions
this year now when you look at the film
the flash players are still there the
guy can throw the ball down the field he
could drop it in the bucket he moves
very very well it's just decision-making
you're wondering how much was in that
offense we go back to evaluations in the
past like Josh Allen like Daniel Jones
where you sit there and say man those
guys are dropping the ball nobody's open
the offensive line isn't blocking anyone
they're overcompensating and trying to
do too much I think you saw Jordan love
do that in the LSU game when he turned
the ball over three times so there's
things I'm very excited about what
you're in love but much like Josh Allen
I think ultimately I'll have him in the
middle of the second round just because
the concerns are very very evident and
you need the right offensive system and
coaching staff to develop the bad habits
out of him yeah he's got some there's
some definitely some wrinkles that
you're gonna have to iron out and I
think I know a lot of Colts fans have
fallen in love with Jordan Love and say
this could be our guy they have I think
with him you have to be very careful
because the traits are intriguing and
you mentioned the LSU game I actually
like some of the things he did against
LSU but the decision-making has been
really bad this year and that's you know
when I'm evaluating quarterbacks now
guys you throw it
captions in college they throw
interceptions in the NFL it's just how
it goes usually don't completely take
that away from a player look at Jameis
Winston right now it's just it is who
they are so we're Jordan love I I
definitely worry about that a little bit
now one thing we did wonder Alabama not
in the college football playoff for the
first time ever what is that gonna do to
the players who were declared for the
draft our guys gonna play in the bowl
game
it sounds like Terrell Lewis the edge
rusher and shavonne digs the corner both
seniors are not gonna participate in the
bowl game it sounds like though Connor
we're gonna see both these guys at the
Senior Bowl I don't think that's
confirmed yet but it the rumors may be
over there yeah so maybe maybe shouldn't
tell I haven't confirmed that but it
sounds like they're both gonna be there
I like both players I think Terrell
Louis a guy putting around one on our
mock draft Monday this could be big for
them understand I'm not playing in the
ball game as seniors especially but I
think the Senior Bowl could be big for
both players yeah and I think by the
time this show comes out the Senior Bowl
surprise announcement should be official
as well but when you look at Louis Matt
we keep we're getting in a trend this
time of year where I'm sure our
listeners are noticing there are certain
guys that have a gigantic opportunity in
front of them these next couple months
to go from round three kind of players
to round one kind of players and that's
because they might have started the year
off slow they might have been playing
through an injury but now you get
healthy you go through the process
you'll be on an at you'll be on an
actionable football field down in Mobile
Alabama with live action drills in a
live action game and then you can get to
the combine and show athletic you are so
when you look at Louis I think Christian
Fulton is the guy that comes to mind we
talked about on Monday was playing
through a couple injuries this year it's
an exciting time of year for these
players because their draft season
starts right now yeah absolutely does
right let's take a break we come back
around Matt Ryan and then we're gonna
finish out the show with Christmas gifts
for all 32 teams we have a great
surprise for you today we didn't know
this one was coming but we will always
make time for the great Matt Ryan Connor
who's joining us thanks to Gatorade Matt
you actually got to surprise a high
school player with a pretty cool award
what was that process like for you yeah
it was awesome
I got to surprise Eric Gilbert this
morning with the 2019 national gainer a
football player of the Year award and I
was in the weight room with with his
teammates and his coaching staff and
some of the administrators from the
school and we were able to surprise him
with that so it was special and great to
meet him and his teammates who just want
to state championship this past weekend
so fun fun day for me that's awesome
Matt now we were wondering before does
Gary just give you a lifetime supply of
it
that's what I'm hoping for you know a
lifetime supply of lemon-lime that's a
microwave flavor so yeah I'll be hitting
him up for that later on today I like
that you're a flavor guy and not a color
guy because I was sick last week and
someone was going to get me Gator and
they're like what color do you want they
are colored guy I guess flavor your
Gatorade sponsor you know that you know
the flavors but we do want to ask you
some questions about the season man the
NFL 100 list just came out and I've had
my bones to pick with it but what is it
like not having Julio Jones on the NFL
100 list at wide receiver a guy who you
know him better than anyone the league
you guys just tore apart my 49ers
together a couple days ago what it what
were your thoughts for Julio not being
there well he's certainly deserving to
be in there and I think ultimately at
the end of the day whenever his career
is done he'll go down as one of the
greatest of all time to do it at his
position there's no question about that
he's he's gonna be in a gold jacket he's
gonna have his bust up there and Canton
and and maybe it was just a little too
soon for this list to come out but he's
he's definitely deserving of it and one
of the you know great players of our
generation now Matt being a Boston
College guy they're obviously relevant
in the news right now making a new hire
from Ohio State with Jeff haffley you
know what do you think of this hire do
you have any history with him and how
excited are you for a new era of Boston
College football well I'm excited I got
to you know text with Jeff a little bit
after he was hired and and watched his
press conference and you know thought he
did a great job and
is going to bring a great energy to BC I
don't really have a history with him but
he is a history with people that you
know I've worked with in San Francisco
with Kyle Shanahan you know some of the
former players that that I've gone
against have relationships with Jessen
and everybody raves about him and says
you know he's a great guy and will do a
great job work extremely hard so I'm
fired up for BC I think it's a great
hire yeah I do want to ask is you
brought Kyle Shanahan up and this is
bittersweet for me as the resident
Niners fan but how how nice is it to see
Kyle on the other side of the field and
to get a win against his Niners who were
red-hot right now
what is there a lot of back and forth
between you two when you're able to best
his team like that uh you know you don't
need to say anything after you've won
you know but we stay in touch a lot and
you know I've texted him throughout the
season it's been fun to watch you know
it's been fun to watch them play and I'm
happy for his success because he's a
good friend of mine and certainly had a
great you know working relationship
together but I'm happy for him and he
deserves it he works extremely hard but
it was nice to get the W on Sunday you
guys obviously got to a Super Bowl
together and it looks like right now for
Kyle even after that loss this weekend
that he has a good chance of getting to
another one this year Matt what does I
mean you worked with him everyday for a
long time what is it that just makes him
so unique and so special well you know I
think as a head coach he he knows
exactly what he wants from from the
players and he knows exactly what he's
looking for at certain spots and I think
you know that first and foremost is his
greatest strength like he knows exactly
what he wants from his X wide receiver
what he wants from his Z wide receiver
what his tight end looks like I think
got a pretty good one in kiddo - I mean
that he's an x-factor for them but then
also he's got a great feel for play
calling and and diagnosing how a defense
is trying to take away certain things
and then being able to expose that I was
always impressed with that during my
time with him Matt you guys have had a
little bit of an up-and-down season but
it seems like you're clicking here late
and there's been a lot
speculation in the media of what's gonna
happen this offseason but does it feel
like in the locker room that you know
you've got some young offensive linemen
especially Lindstrom who's playing
really well lately does it feel like you
guys are kind of catching your momentum
late this year which could build into
something nice next season yeah I think
so I think you know you talked about
Chris who was injured in his first game
and then you know was able to come back
for us and play well the last two weeks
I think he's a guy that these next two
games to finish off the season are
really important from an experience
standpoint for him
but I do think there there's something
to build on there's a momentum that that
we can take into the offseason for these
young guys and in a you know winning in
tough places like New Orleans on the
road or going out to San Francisco
beating a good football team like that
on the road that's huge for young guys
to create belief that you can go out
there and do it and to show what it
takes in order to do that so they have
that that right mindset as we move
forward as a team well Matt thank you so
much for the time today man we really
appreciate it and we're wishing you the
best of luck for the rest of this season
thank you guys I appreciate it
yeah thanks about have a good one all
right see you guys
Merry Christmas NFL team from me and
Connor to you
Connor is gonna take the AFC I'm gonna
take the NFC and remember some of these
are meant to be funny okay so don't get
upset
laughs it's the Christmas spirit that's
a Christmas spirit as my joy as my
six-year-old keeps saying to me you
can't get mad at me it's the Christmas
spirit what's that's amazing everyone
figured it out right what's what's the
one main thing that Emmet wants for
Christmas this year
so Emmet has fallen into a cowboy phase
I have shown you the pictures it was
having boots every day so he wanted a
cheeps
a stuffed animal and a black cowboy hat
that's all he wants for Christmas that's
simple enough yeah Annie he wants to go
to the University of Texas and meet Bevo
which I think I actually think we're
gonna do it we're just gonna roadtrip
down there and I reached out to the
school they were like yeah we could
probably make that happen so usually my
I wanna meet with Vince young
doesn't want to meet Tom Herman mm-hmm
doesn't want to meet Sam Allen girl and
all three of these things you could
probably set up yeah right he's a weird
but that's great man I mean he wants to
go to Texas for Christmas can't get
upset with that all right up first the
NFC East the Dallas Cowboys I am gifting
you the one thing you all want Lincoln
Riley as head coach this also helps me
as a Texas fan because you got to get
him out of the big 12 where he's killing
all of us the Philadelphia Eagles what
you guys need a healthy speedy wide
receiver you can call him Henry rugs if
you want ylvis' cachet know whoever it
is I'm giving you guys speed and health
at the receiver position the Washington
Redskins the only thing that could save
your franchise Merry Christmas
it's a new owner Dan Snyder may finally
sells the team to Jeff Beezus or
something get him out of there and the
New York Giants another generational
prospect I don't know how you guys get
this lucky with the number two overall
pick you get another freak show in chase
young at number two overall in the 2020
draft all right over on the AFC East the
Buffalo Bills Matt if I had to ask you
what would you say was the last time the
Bills want a playoff game
1994 1995 very close it has been a very
long time for those loyal fans up in
Buffalo as you get way off when the
bills they have a shot this year
great defense Trey white who definitely
deserves to be in the Defensive Player
of the Year conversation
Josh Allen has really cut down the
turnovers they've gotten a lot of
impacts from free agents and rookies
this year and the most important thing
is they're a very well coached football
team I'm not sitting here and saying the
bills are gonna make a deep run but I
think the Bills can really break that
playoff win drought or at least have a
chance to they have a chance to do it so
a playoff win for the Buffalo Bills for
Christmas this year late Christmas
president the New England Patriots this
one for me it's been a rough year for
injuries on the offensive line for New
England but I think this is the team
that should go out and trade for Trent
Williams so when you look at Trent
now I think it's gonna be it's safe to
say it's over in Washington now with New
England there was rumors they were
interested in in trying to acquire him
when Washington did not want to move him
I don't know if Tom Brady will be back
but I'm not gonna sit here and tell you
he won't be and if you have Tom Brady
back there at his age you need a really
good offensive line so trading for Trent
Williams would probably be ideal for
them the New York Jets not saying this
one's gonna happen but it's Christmas
you should believe in miracles
Matt rule comes back for another
interview and the Jets finally give him
what he wants after they miraculously
fire Adam GaSe I think they're gonna be
dumb enough to stick out with Adam GaSe
but the best Christmas gift for Jets
fans this year would be to have a
mulligan and get Matt rule in the
coaching cycle this year the Miami
Dolphins listen they're probably not
picking number one which means they
probably don't get Broadway Joe burrow
which is a shame for Dolphins fans but I
think I've been watching burrow a lot of
promising takeaways this year for them
under Brian Flores and maybe a guy named
- it's a goodbye Aloha with the injury
now Falls to them I think it healthy to
a healthy TOA is being the key there
would be the best draft and Christmas
scenario for the Miami Dolphins Broadway
jobber oh that's good it's not fun when
he goes to the Bengals that's the
problem no no I don't we got a lot about
that though and it's like his speech
about you know southeast Ohio and how
much that area means to him
it's it's perfect that he goes back to
the Bengals he's probably gonna set up a
foundation that races like JJ Watt money
for that area so it does make some sense
all right the NFC North the Chicago
Bears I will be in Chicago Sunday
looking forward to hanging out with a
lot of Bears fans my presence you guys
is couples therapy for Matt nagging mr.
Bisky because they're not on the same
page right now you heard it after the
game Sunday Mitch is frustrated Matt
feels like he can't call the plays he
wants to play they need to get together
in a room and hash this out figure out
who's causing the problems couples
therapy didn't work for me but hopefully
it works for these guys the Green Bay
Packers ten more years Aaron Rodgers is
all you guys need you have one of the
greatest quarterbacks
of all time Matt Lafleur seems to be
doing great things they're just a
healthy a rod for the next 10 years to
be great the Minnesota Vikings it's a
hard one what does this team need
healthy Dalvin cook maybe assets on the
offensive line I think what you really
need a shutdown corner because you have
to deal with all those playmakers in the
NFC North if you're ever gonna catch
teams like the Saints the Seahawks the
nine years gonna have to shut people
down I'm gonna give you Paulson a Deebo
somehow he falls to you in the first
round and then the Detroit Lions a
mulligan is what this team needs a
do-over a GM and head coach don't try to
be the New England Patriots go do your
own thing start over at GM and head
coach because I liked the map Patricia
hire I thought his toughness would be
good for them they have completely
mismanaged this thing look at the impact
to Diggs is having in Seattle that's the
kind of guy you build a team around they
traded him for whatever reason they need
a completely new GM they need a new head
coach finally get Matt Stafford some
help there yeah Patricia is starting to
feel like a a watered down version of
Eric Mangini over there where he's
trying to do things his way
at least Mangini drafted guys like Revis
at the end of the day it didn't work out
but when it comes down to it Patricia is
just very my way or the highway and
that's what ended managing his career in
a couple different places as much as I
was a fan of him that's what did him in
and they have seen North the Pittsburgh
Steelers they need a little duck luck
this year for Christmas you got to make
good game this weekend against the Jets
get the duck right especially if Jamal
Adams doesn't play get his confidence
level up before this postseason before
you got to play the Ravens to close out
the year although be interesting to see
Matt if the Ravens actually are resting
players keep that duck luck going two
weeks in a row get hot before the
playoffs the Cleveland Browns this is
simple the guys name that's a suitabie
Santa Claus for you this year is Ron
Rivera move on from Freddy Hitchens
get a professional football coach in
there that can coach up this defense get
a professional offensive coordinator
working under him or keep Todd Monken
I'd be fine with that although they'll
clean house if they fire the coaches
that's very TBD Ron Rivera should be the
guy for the Browns Baltimore Ravens this
is the easiest gift you can give out the
gift of health because if you stay
healthy your problem
winning the Super Bowl it's as easy as
that Cincinnati Bengals this one's
different we know they're probably
getting Joe borough number one overall
they need to hit on that number 33 pick
and it needs to be an offensive lineman
to protect geo borough this is not a
good offensive line this is not an
offense now Jonah Williams coming back
and definitely helped out but you're
still a couple pieces away where we're
gonna talk about that number one pick
non-stop it's about time we start
talking about how important that first
pick or second pick of round 2 will be
yeah then it's gonna be huge for them
thank God he has Tyler Boyd to throw it
to so he's got a couple weapons to work
with there all right let's take a break
we come back we're gonna hit the NFC and
AFC South and the NFC and AFC West it is
present time for the NFC South the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers the one thing you guys
all need as I squint at the camera in
front of me LASIK coupons for Jameis
Winston fix this man's vision and maybe
he won't be throwing interceptions on
the first drive oh I did see their four
and one when he throws a pick on the
first drive so maybe he just needs like
get one out of a system and then he's
good to go
but Jameis needs to do something about
the division get that corrected the
Carolina Panthers this year's wash next
year probably will be to just keep
Trevor Lawrence in the Carolina's build
this franchise around him that's the
best present I can give you going from
Cam Newton to Trevor Lawrence the New
Orleans Saints you need another wide
receiver but we all know Drew Brees
isn't gonna throw to him anyway because
he has Michael Thomas so whilst throw
one out there just to make it a little
more challenging for defenses but Thomas
with his 150 catches this year looks
unstoppable right now anyway
everything Atlanta Falcons I'm gonna
give you more time because I think like
we've heard from our friend Matt Ryan
they're clicking they just need more
time
I actually think Jan Quinn's a good head
coach they just got off to a bad start
this year with some injuries like matt
said they beat the Saints on the road
they beat the Niners on the road it's a
good team that's just gelling a little
bit late in the year
all right the AFC South the Indianapolis
Colts I mean man there's no bigger lump
of coal than Andrew Luck retiring and
now you need ed Dodds to stay there I
think ed Dodds will get some GM
interviews if he wants to take them this
off-season Chris Ballard is a great GM
but you want these guys working together
to find your quarterback of the future
while you continue to build this team I
like Jacoby Brissette
he's a nice bridge option option a nice
band-aid option he's somebody that you
can win games with I just wonder if he's
the guy that can go out and win you a
lot of football games so Edie dots
saying there and evaluating the talent
will be key for the Colts I don't know
if they're gonna get that lucky this
might be the year that he gets a job the
Tennessee Titans get that Ryan Tannehill
extension done this is obviously Mike
rables guy if Tana Hills playing at a
high level right now it's pretty
impressive when you consider that he
came in at a you know a midpoint of the
season in this playing like this I think
if you go into an offseason you get him
at a reasonable number he's not gonna
command some absolutely absurd kind of
contract not what Zach Prescott's asking
for right now which dak has earned I
think you can build the right offense
around Tannehill and this defense will
be good enough where the Titans there'll
be a little window there for them to
compete to take the AFC South in the
near future the Houston Texans
you just need JJ Watt back and healthy
and ready to go and you can make some
noise because when this guy is on he's
one of the best defensive players in the
NFL so I know the Gift of Health is a
very very easy one it's something we
gave to the Ravens but if JJ Watt can
come back that can give this team the
spark that they need Jacksonville
Jaguars you need a makeover a complete
makeover I don't know if we got to send
you Jon Taffer I don't know if we need
to do what is it you think fixer-upper
just bring all of the celebrity fixing
people you have send them to
Jacksonville and start from scratch
and that does not mean move to London
but that means to hire the right people
where grievances aren't being filed at
an alarming rate to the NFLPA where you
won't have to spend 9 billion dollars
for a free agency jaxa build this thing
can be saved but we're calling bar
rescue to get it right for Christmas
this year I just pictured Jon Taffer
like tearing out seats and putting TVs
in and like yelling at people to shut it
down like Gardner Minshew
right there it's just amazing uh man we
were supposed to have Taffer on the show
a long time ago and it felt the right
way
Bar rescue the Jaguars he's like closing
the pool you know he can't keep that
[ __ ] clean shut it down all right NFC
West the Arizona Cardinals they need an
elite offensive line coach because I
think they have something with Kliff
Kingsbury and Kyler Murray just got to
protect Kyler now keep him healthy the
LA Rams more draft picks is what this
team needs but we know they would just
trace them for defenders anyway so I
don't know why they would get more draft
picks the Seattle Seahawks you need
Jadeveon Clowney back at a discount if I
could give you anything it would be
cloudy falling in love with the Pacific
Northwest taking a little bit of a
hometown discount because when a healthy
I don't know if it's been talked about
enough how impactful he's been this year
he's been fantastic for my San Francisco
49ers the one thing they need right now
is a healthy roster west of Rick Berg
Goes Down that's a huge injury to them
Richard Sherman's been out we've talked
about that one is enormous
the Niners a lot like you said with the
Ravens Connor it feels like if they
could just stay healthy it seems good
enough to beat anyone especially in the
NFC just getting the entire roster back
together I'm not even talking about the
running backs I don't even need those
guys because you can put Raheem mustard
in and he'll rush for 200 yards in three
touchdowns but getting a healthy on the
o-line getting healthy in the secondary
seems to be the only thing standing
between the Niners and going to Miami
yeah I mean and also les Snead has never
seen a draft Vick he didn't want to
trade the AFC West here the Chiefs got a
little crazy idea it sounds like the
Jets are just gonna be willing to dump
levy on Bell in the offseason and
they'll probably have to eat some of the
money in that contract now I know the
Chiefs aren't swimming in cap space but
with a lot of the guaranteed money left
on the 2020 part of the deal
maybe the Chiefs can dump off a fourth
round draft pick for levy on bail that
would be fun to watch in Kansas City
with bill Bell's ability to pass protect
from mahomes his ability to run between
the tackles and a cushion to it Warren
Lee as a pass catcher a coach that can
use him because the coach is not blind
in Andy Reed so when you look at I love
that matchup and I think that's a fit
that makes sense if the Jets are really
gonna move him in this offseason the
Broncos they need an offensive tackle
and they need one of these good ones to
fall to them in this trap and you're
Thomas Jedrek wills tristan worse they
need
somebodyís offensive tackle they're
gonna go into next year with Trulock
keep your young quarterback protected
the Los Vegas Raiders Matt talked about
it on mock draft Monday it's time for a
new quarterback I don't know if that guy
will be a developmental player like
Jordan love I don't know if they'll kick
the can down the road one more year and
wait it out for Trevor Lawrence Justin
fields that quarterback group Derek Carr
it doesn't exactly scream Las Vegas to
me it's time to find Gruden's guy of
this Gruden era part to the Chargers
they need a quarterback as well but they
need one to fall in this draft they need
two of the fall I maybe they'll take
Herbert and things will work out over
there
but the Chargers it's probably over for
Philip Rivers I think you could start
Tyrod Taylor next year while you're
getting a rookie ready they've won a
decent amount of games this year where
they're not sitting in this window it's
a guarantee to get a quarterback maybe
they get creative and make a trade but
the Chargers on afford I love Philip
Rivers unfortunately it's gonna be time
for a new face of the franchise at the
signal caller position for them yeah I
love it
those are gifts I want to ask you a
question that was not prepared and this
is completely off the rails but drew
brees passes Peyton Manning all-time
touchdown record and Tom Brady's gonna
pass him soon do you think Drew Brees is
a top five all-time quarterback yes okay
I do too that I've seen yeah I mean yeah
if so for me like it starts with prime
Montana I mean like it the Montana era
so I think Brees the top-five
quarterback the the stick to football
Hall of Famers are arguing like
intensely about this on Twitter because
there's some Peyton Manning guys in
there there's some Favre guys in there I
think it's Brady Montana and then after
that it's like a conversation like Elway
breeze Marino Favre I don't think I
don't know if Peyton's top five oh wow I
think yes but he's in the conversation
right I mean I could look like seven
guys that are top five is the problem
it's tricky
I think Brees it's it would be pretty
insane to leave Brees off I mean you
know what it is with Brees like when you
think of Favre an Elway you think of
like the run
and firing the ball sixty yards down the
field and like that fiery energy and
when you think of Brady you think of
eight million Super Bowls and just and
really being the greatest of all time
when you think of Manning you think of
like the architect of lightweight modern
offense and being brilliant when you
think of Brees you think of just how
pinpoint accurate he is and I don't know
if that gets people revved up the same
way as the other things but to me it's
one of the most important out of them
all
I think his deep ball is I think it's
the prettiest he's the prettiest deep
ball thrower I've ever seen
for me breezes a lock in my top five
yeah luck I will say that I'm not just
trying to poke the stick to football
hall of fame bear dan barnes tweeted
that peyton manning is has five MVP
awards that's a popularity vote i mean
that's all that is the top rating should
have 12 if you were really giving it to
the best player in the league I think
MVP is like that's like being a pro
bowler anymore you know it means you're
a quarterback in the media likes you
that's what that me it doesn't really
hold that same kind of way and I mean
speaking of MVPs like Eli Manning is a
two-time Super Bowl MVP at least one of
those should have went to a defensive
lineman right or David Tyree you know
what I mean like the MVP thing is just
that's a week that's a weak argument my
don't like I don't like using MVPs this
goes back to I mean Jill burrow deserved
the Heisman this year don't get me wrong
but there's been a lot of Heisman
winners before him where you're like
wasn't the best player in college I'm
right yeah usually Smith come on
I mean Derek Henry although Derek
Henry's shutting me up this year he
looks really same same same that's our
show
yeah I just want to throw something fun
in there at the end it's fun it's a good
show God we got Matt Ryan on I loved
seeing him go to bat for his guy Julio
and you know obviously the Gatorade
thing was really cool imagine being
surprised by Matt Ryan in a red Player
of the Year
oh I would be amazing I can't when I was
a high school kid I always tried to go
to those like Chiefs camps and stuff
I can't imagine like walking into the
locker room be like oh there's Matt Ryan
just holding your trophy and a bottling
a bottle of your favorite flavor of
Gatorade great or color whatever it
might be
all right that is our show we'll be back
Friday morning and I have no idea what
we're gonna talk about so it's gonna be
a fun one